- It's amazing how people can't
differentiate between say,
the narrow AI that allows a car
to figure out what a lane line is
and navigate streets versus
general intelligence.
These are just very different things.
Like your toaster and your
computer are both machines,
but one is much more
sophisticated than another.
- You're confident with
Tesla you can create
the world's best toaster?
- The world's best toaster, yes.
The world's best self-driving...
Yes, to me, right now
this seems game, set, match.
I don't wanna be complacent
or over confident
but that is just literally
how it appears right now.
I could be wrong but it
appears to be the case
that Tesla is vastly ahead of everyone.